Je me souviens
d’une dissertation d’économie.
Le sujet était sur la dette publique,
c’était quand je préparais
le concours de l’ENA.
Dans la dernière partie
de la dissertation,
j’avais commencé en disant
que la piste évidente
pour réduire la dette publique,
c’est tout simplement
de réduire les dépenses.
Dans l’absolu,
l’idée est simple
et pertinente.
Mais le prof m’a expliqué
le problème avec cette idée
lorsqu’il ma rendu ma copie.
Il m’a dit grosso modo :
« Vous vous rendez compte
que vous allez probablement être corrigé
par un haut fonctionnaire
dont la mission QUOTIDIENNE
est de trouver des solutions
pour ACCROÎTRE LES RECETTES
pour FAIRE RENTRER
de l’argent
dans les caisses de l’État
— et vous,
la première solution
que vous lui présentez,
c’est de
RÉDUIRE LES DÉPENSES.
Ça revient à lui dire
qu’il fait n’importe quoi ! »
C’est ce jour-là
que j’ai vraiment compris :
il faut se mettre
À LA PLACE
du correcteur !
Je crois que,
COMME MOI
lorsque j’étais encore étudiant,
vous avez besoin
d’une petite piqûre de pragmatisme.
Vous avez tendance à l’oublier,
mais vos dissertations
ne sont pas corrigées par
un logiciel !
Alors certes,
pour certaines épreuves,
les correcteurs suivent un barème,
mais la dissertation,
ça ne sera jamais
comme les maths !
En définitive,
l’évaluation comportera toujours
une bonne part de subjectivité.
Moi qui corrige
EN ILLIMITÉ
toutes les copies des membres
de ma formation avancée
à la méthodologie de la dissertation,
je peux vous le dire :
je fais tout mon possible
pour être JUSTE,
mais il y a plein de facteurs
qui biaisent mon appréciation
— je suis parfois de mauvaise humeur,
certains jours au contraire
je veux être gentil,
ou peut-être même qu’Haristote
vient de faire une connerie.
D’un côté,
je suis rodé,
parce que j’ai corrigé beaucoup de copies
depuis pas mal d’années ;
mais de l’autre côté,
je ne serai jamais une machine.
C’est pour ça que vous DEVEZ
vous mettre
à la place du correcteur ;
essayer de comprendre
son contexte de travail,
d’entrer dans sa tête,
d’imaginer ses motivations,
ses émotions,
etc.
tout ça pour déterminer
TRÈS PRÉCISÉMENT
ce qui lui plaît
— et qui va donc
vous faire gagner des points —
et ce qui lui déplaît
— et qui va donc
vous faire PERDRE
des points.
En tout cas,
une chose qui vous fera gagner des points
À TOUS LES COUPS,
c’est LA MÉTHODO.
Enfin,
pas n’importe quelle méthodo
— une méthodologie SIMPLE
et EFFICACE.
Vous en voulez une ?
Inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Vous m’en direz des nouvelles,
et vous verrez qu’une fois
que vous aurez assimilé mon cours,
tout sera plus clair dans votre esprit,
et vous connaîtrez L’ESSENTIEL
pour séduire le correcteur.
Comme c’est un cours par e-mail,
vous pourrez le découvrir après la vidéo,
ou dans les prochains jours.
Là maintenant tout de suite,
préparez-vous à regarder
ATTENTIVEMENT
cette vidéo,
parce que je vais
vous dire des choses
que vous n’entendrez pas
dans une salle de classe.
Regardez attentivement cette vidéo
JUSQU’AU BOUT
et vous gagnerez plusieurs points
DÈS
votre prochaine épreuve de
dissertation.
Vous croyez
que ça ressemble à ça,
la correction d’une dissertation ?
Bon,
je pense que vous le savez :
le correcteur a BEAUCOUP
de copies à corriger.
S’il est prof dans une prépa,
ou à l’université,
il a généralement plusieurs classes,
donc il a minimum cinquante
cent copies
à corriger en même temps.